[音楽]
私は幼いころ体力がなくスポーツができず勉強もできない
そんなこともでした
そんな私の最初の夢はそう魔法使いになることでした
しかしほどなくして私は知りました
どうやらあれは嘘らしい
少し泣きました
でちょっと泣いたあとですね
私は今度はドラえもんを手に入れることを企てました
彼のあのひみつ道具があればどんなに楽しいだろう
あの道具があればこんなことができる
絶対に伸びたよりも上手にある
そういう自信がありました
ところがほどなくしてまた私は知ってしまった
ドラえもんが生まれる22世紀まで自分がおそらく生きることができないということ
そしてその時はもう本当に泣きました
ひとしきり泣いたと思いついたんです
22世紀が待てないのであれば
自分でひみつ道具を作ればいいと
我が家は少し特殊でした私が父から守らされたのは
人を傷つけないことそして人の物を盗まないことこの2つです
これさえ守っていれば多少社会のルールから外れようが
いえだいぶ社会からのルールから外れても何も言わない
桑葉屋でした結構とんでもないと思います
ただそんな私はそれに気を良くして
小学校の頃からやれ図書館に行きたい
家で秋葉原に行きたいと学校休みがちでした
当然友達なんかできません人付き合いもわかりませんでした
そんな私を救ってくれたのは自分が作ったいくつかのひみつ道具でした
忍者の博水雲のようなもの
ロケット花火をある時間の後自動的に配車する装置
そんなターンのないものでしたただある時から周りの人が何人か実験を手伝ってくれる
ようになりました
それで私は少しずつ人とのつきあい方を覚えていきました
気をよくした私は
足が遅いのであれば電気で走るスケボ
泳げないのであれば発泡指導で船をと自分自身の努力じゃなく
できないことをできるようにするひみつ道具を作ることで解決を図るようになってき
ました
そんな子供がそのまま大人になったそれが私です
今日は皆さんにこんな私が仲間と作ったいくつかのひみつ道具を紹介したいと思います
あるとき私は思いました
空を自由に飛びたいなぁ
子供の時じゃないですよだいぶいい年になってからです
最初は例のタケコプターですねあれみたいに自分自身を飛ばすことを考えました
ただ今の技術ではすごい巨大な装置になります
運搬して組み立てて
動作確認をして
周囲の安全に排除して安全点検して最後に
うん4曲
許可をとってですねその後やと飛び出すことができる
なので私はこう思いました今思い立ってすぐ飛び立てるそんな道具が必要だ
そして作ったのが x とコプターという道具です
これは
自分自身ではなくその自分の分身を空に飛ばします
映像の奥で私が立って掃除をしています
この x とコプターカメラと2本のアームが付いています
カメラは
vr ゴーグルを通じて自分の目となるアームは自分の動きを計測する kinect
という装置を使って自分の手と同じように動きます
自分の動き自分の体で行うことでそれをそのまま遠くにあるロボットに伝えることが
できるそういうロボットです
作ってみた結果わかったことがあります
とても酔うんです
カメラで撮った映像は微妙な遅れを伴って自分の面届きます
この数百ミリ秒というわずかな奥では私たち乗り物酔いと同じような効果を見ます
医師の vr 酔いと
の質の一つですね
忠この問題は核の技術とともに徐々に解決されつつあり
2020年にはより良いものが作れるそういうふうに目論んでいます
ですねこのドローン最近何かと悪い方向で有名になってしまいましたが
とても面白くて高い将来性があることは間違いありません
そんなドローンおこうよない子っていうとですね
いろんなものが作りたくなるんですね
次にこのドローンを使用したひみつ道具一つお見せします
動画を流しますのでこれが一転何をする動画なのか当てて頂ければと思います
意見普通のドローンなんですが特徴的なのはこの先端についている
このもふもふっとしてやつですね
このもふもふ
自由に角度を調整できるアームの先端についています
そして
ドリルのようにぐるぐるもあります
またカメラがついていて目標物を認識して自動でゆっくりと
近づいていきます
もうちょい
終わっちゃう
そろそろは仮ですかねぇ
これ
世界初
洗車をするドローンです
グルと言います
でたですねまあ皆さん多分頭の中にあると思うんですがこれで洗車するのは馬鹿だろう
と
あまりにも効率が悪すぎますそこで活躍するのがこの
くるという相棒のロボットです
クルルは自動車の表面に張り付いて表面のほこりをくるくると
沼のように落としていきます
車のだいたいの汚れは
毎日こうやって継続的にホコリを落とすことでだいぶ抑えることができます
ただそれだけでは取りきれ例えば鳥の糞みたいな汚れがあった時にこのクルルは先ほど
のグルールに競演要請を出します
でグルールは呼ばれると自分の充電ステーションから飛び立ち
くるの位置を自動で認識してで洗剤のついたブラシで局所的な清掃を行う
そういうシステムです
作ってみた結果これにもですねたくさんの課題が見つかりました
ここではあげません
ただ私の車にはこの時に付いたたくさんの傷がう
今でも残っています
次にですねあの私たちがこのドローンと同じぐらい注力している
ひみつ道具人の移動手動モビリティについてご紹介したいと思います
自動車をはじめとしたモビリティ
外見上こそそんなに大きな変化がないですが中身はとても新しい技術が数多く投入され
ています
そんなモビリティの分野で新しい使い方や使われ方こういったものを提案できるものを
私たちは作っています
トヨタ自動車を育てた豊田英二さんがこういったといいます
理想の車とは孫悟空が乗る均等であると
きんとんは雲のような外観を持ち呼べば颯爽と現れて乗れば自由自在に動き回ることが
でき目的地を釣れば
連れてってくれるそしてで決して事故を起こさな
真に受けた私たちはこれを実際に作ってみることにしました
できたのコレです
きんとんと言います
残念ながら空はまだときません
特徴的なのはこの外観です風船でできています
スバル人の形状に合わせてとものように自由自在に形を変えます
金とにはカメラとレーザーセンサーが付いており
障害物を避けながら自動的に目的地に向かったり
自分の飼い主を見分けて
あと荷物を持ってついていったり他にもおしゃべりをしたり
嫌いな人が乗ると振り落としてっ
結構実用的な機能を盛り込みました
そんな中でもですね特にいろんな人に喜んでいただけたのはこの機能です
指差し操縦金を取ります
きんとんは特殊な腕輪型のセンサーを付けることで操縦することができます
そのウェアをつけていきたい方向を指さすとその方向に向かいます
映像でプロ衣服の彼が指差した方向にこの子どもを乗せた金盗んだ
向かってているのがわかると思います
この機能
お年寄りから子どもまで一度体験すれば誰でも自由自在に操縦できるそういう機能に
なりました
この誰でもという点でこのきんとんとても大きな気づきを私たちに与えてくれました
誰でも乗れるもビーティこれを考えたとき私たちは無意識のうちに健常者を対象にして
いることに気がつきました
そこで私たちはその枠を広げて障害者の方も乗れる藻 bt にしたいそう思いました
作ったのはこの100ずホイールという車いす型の藻 bt です
世の中にはたっくさんの車いす型のモビリティが提案されています
ただそのほとんどすべてが障害者の方のみに向けて作られています
私たちはそうではなく
障害者も健常者も誰でも乗ることができる
そんな藻 bt にしたい
それを実現することで真のバリアフリーを実現するそんな藻 bt にしたいと思い
ました
正しい健常者が思わず乗ってみたいそう思ってくれるようにするためには何が必要か
考えた結果まず
かっこよくあること
そして足よりも便利であること
さらに楽しいことこれが重要だと考えました
質問です
このエグゾホイールカコワルイ思われる方
てあげてください勇気を持っ
ちょっと多いえっ
まあ
であればだいたいただですね今何人かの方てあげていただきましたが大体80%の
くらいの方が超かっこいい
そう言ってくれるモビリティ仕上がりました
よくあるアンケートの取り方ですね
ただこの f ホイールかっこいいだけじゃないんです
通常このような車いす型藻 bt こんなスティック型のコントローラーを使って操縦
します
なので片手はいつも操縦に専念しなくちゃいけません
そうすると操縦中に自由に使えるて片方の手だけになります
一歩エグゾホイールは体の姿勢
型抜きで操縦することができますそのため健常者が何気なくを行っている例えば
両手にものを持って移動するですとか片手にものを持ってドアを開ける
こんな動きを当たり前のように実現することができます
またもう一つこの映像ホイール大きな特徴があります
それは
スポーツモードというモードに変形することでスポーツができるということです
スキーのような動きで高速に素早く動き回ることができます
両手が自由に使え素早く動けますのでこのようにインラインホッケー
ラクロスバスケットボールなど数々のスポーツを楽しむことができます
いつの日か健常者と障害者が同じものを使って同じるーるー
日常生活もスポーツを楽しむことができるそんな藻 bt にしていきたいと考えてい
ます
最後にこのスポーツという観点でもう一つひみつ道具をご紹介します
よく
高度に発達した科学は魔法と見分けがつかないということが言われます
ただこの言葉高度に発達した科学が結果としてたまたまなんとなく魔法のように見える
ちょっと消極的な感じがしますなので私たちはもっとこれはアクティブに
魔法の世界を科学と技術で実装しそれをスポーツの世界に持ち込みたいそう考えました
私たちが実装しようとした魔法の世界それはこちらです
わかりますか
映画ハリーポッターの中で大人気のスポーツ9立地です
この9リッジができたらどんなに楽しいだろう
そう思い私たちはこの9リッジを実際にプレイできるシステム
エクスとブルームを開発しています
9リッジをプレイするのに一番最初に必要なのはもちろんこの放棄です
それではさっそく登場してもらいましょうどうぞ
プレーヤーは彼坂本君のようにインラインスケートを履いて大きい方も bt に
またがります
アクセル操作ブレイク操作は手元のセンサーで直感的に行うことができます
慣れるとこのように自由自在に動き回ることができます
ちなみにこの方キー方もビーティかで坂本くんが電子回路制御を担当しています
こんな顔してますけどモデルじゃないですちゃんと一流のエンジニアです
そしてですねこの creech プレイするためにもう一つ必要なもの
これですねスギッチと言われる魔法道具です
人から逃げ回る
まぁちょっと厄介なボールですね
これは私たちはドローンを使って実現しました
このドローンにはカメラが付いておりプレイヤーを認識し自由に逃げ回ることができ
ます
で
これの他にやっとこれでやと区立がプレイできると思いきや
スポーツの世界にはまだもうちょっと大切なものがあります何か
わかりますか
のビザにとってのじゃあやー
国にとってのベジた
ハリーにとっての
曾丸保井ライバルですねなので私たちはこの大がた藻 bt コストを抑えて簡単に
作れるようにし量産することができるようになりました
どうぞ
ご紹介しましょう
彼小林君はこの放棄がた藻 bt のメカ設計デザインそして先ほど出てきたエグゾ
ホイール
それも担当しています
ところがですね
高
彼つい先日までこの放棄がた藻 bt 乗ることができませんでした
なんだかわかりますか
まあ運動神経ですねはい
でところがですねまぁ今日のためにたくさん練習してこのようにちょっと同じ動きしか
できませんが
なんとかね乗れるようになってくれました
どうか彼の努力に拍手お願いします
この x とブルームですねこのあとほんの少しの時間ではありますが体験して
いただくことができます
すごく面白もになりましたのでぜひ大外で体験していただければと思います
ありがとう
はあああ
[拍手]
さて今日ご紹介したこれらのひみつ道具これは全部販売を目的としたものではありませ
ん
じゃあなんでつくるのか
私たちにとってものづくりとは手段であると同時に目的でもあります
実際にカー自分たちで考えたものも作り試し
いろんな人に体験してもらってそこから新しい学びを得てそれを次のものづくりに
フィードバックする
それはものすごく楽しくて刺激的でかけがえのない体験です
人の歴史はものづくりと共にありました
その結果を消費しているのが今の私たちだと私は思っています
今度は私達の番です
今日では知識がなくともアプリを簡単に作ることができます
どんなに不器用でも
自動で精密な工作を行うことができます
作り方に見当がつかなくても
キーボード少し叩けば先人たちの素晴らしい地キャン
そして仲間を見つけることができます
ものづくりは人と人をつなげて新しい可能性を満たします
みなさんの中からたくさんのひみつ道具が生まれることを心から願っています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]